[Music]
the Biden Administration will require
negative covid tests from people coming
to the U.S from China beginning January
5th the new rules apply to all Air
passengers over the age of two who must
test negative no more than two days
before their departure this applies to
people of all nationalities and
vaccination status as well as Travelers
who entered the who enter the U.S only
for a connecting flight Ohio Congressman
Bradley Winship is a member of the GOP
doctor's caucus and house intelligence
committee and joins us now Congressman
great to have you here we'll have you
put your Congressman hat on in a second
but first the doctors had if you will
how worried are you about China's
complete lockdown followed by complete
rollback and how that's going to impact
us our health here in the U.S
well hopefully it won't impact our
health here in the United States but we
saw the negative effects of complete
lockdowns here in the United States when
we did that and we saw that so many
people were affected in other ways
because they weren't getting their
medical care Etc so I'm curious how
that's going to play out in China
hopefully they won't be spreading into
other parts of the world like it likely
happened and seemingly did happen when
covet first began so hopefully it won't
be affecting the United States but we've
got to move in better directions Dr
fauci is a about to retire but that
doesn't mean that we aren't finished
asking him a lot of questions as a
member of Congress sitting on the
intelligence committee you know so what
message does this send that the U.S is
moving forward with this should we be
concerned about something in the near
future with the covid origin
uh moving ahead with the policies in
China or moving ahead with uh origins of
covid which certainly I've invested a
lot of time in over the last couple
years and and I think we need to invest
more uh you know the origins of cobot
are very important as we have Lessons
Learned after action review what did we
do what did we do right what did we do
wrong uh what what are the effectiveness
of the vaccines that have been developed
what's the effectiveness of natural
immunity none of this has really been
addressed in the way that it should be
from a scientific standpoint but the
problem we're having with the
intelligence Community is with the
intelligence Community they're ignoring
a lot of the key evidence it is
important to know the origins of of
covet in the Democrat report of
intelligence committee they said no
reason to look into the origins any
further and I I can't disagree more if
we're going to be able to be prepared
and be ready and not only that from a
national security standpoint if China is
engaging in BIO weapons and bioweapons
research which our state department has
said they are interested in offensive
bioweapons and they said that as far
back as 2005 then we need to be engaged
in the origins of covid and and where
that's leading to and what we have to
look forward to in the future if we're
going to be prepared for a pandemic
ready for a pandemic and also protect
ourselves and our health in the United
States of America is that report that
you all released earlier this month that
it may have been tied to China's
biological weapons research program boy
that seems to me something that you guys
are going to lead off with when you take
off on January 3rd because it's
something that Ashley I everybody should
want an answer to because it is
frightening meantime a majority of
Americans think our country's influence
in the world is getting weaker under the
Biden Administration 47 percent in fact
perception can often become reality
Congress and how do we reverse this
horrifying trend
uh we we have to show True leadership
and and trustworthy leadership in
America uh and for the rest of the world
to see this
um I don't think people around the rest
of the world can can fathom why we have
for example open borders uh why that
we've let this pandemic go on and on
without searching for the truth why we
have people in in leadership uh that are
off vacationing when we have a
transportation problem uh we have to
have active energetic honest trustworthy
people at the helm for the rest of the
world to see and we have to be strong uh
there's there's no problem in seeking
for example the origins of covet and if
that's egg on China's face then so be it
but if you're afraid to go there for
some reason or another then we are going
to look weaker we have to be a country
that appears to be honest when you see
things that are coming out of for
example Twitter now now that Elon Musk
has Twitter and you see a government
that is engaging with media right to
suppress various views you're going to
look weak and you're not going to look
like a free country that we once were
Congressman Dr Brad wenstrip thank you
always so insightful on these topics I'm
Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm
Ainsley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis